hello and welcome back to my channel
it's Leia hi open hair and this week
we're joined with well-known British
journalist John Sweeney Joe Sweeney is
best known for his undercover work at
BBC Panorama when he's taken on Putin I
take my Scientology and even gone
undercover in North Korea so if you like
this video then hit the subscribe button
and hit the bell so you get notified
every single time that I post and drop a
comment below said I mean what topics
you want to hear next week and if you
enjoy the video don't forget to hit the
like button john sweeney such a pleasure
having you today how are you doing I'm
all right I've been um I had a kind of a
mile scare so I've been inside for about
a week today I walked all the way to st.
Paul's and I started living them I live
in Vauxhall it's not that far as
beautiful walk along the river and
horrible as it is I also felt you could
hear when that when the clock on the
Bell toll on st. Paul's you could hear
them so beautifully it was so quiet and
some of this terrible thing that's ruin
all our lives and I hate it I hate it I
hate it I'm sorry but but some of it is
kind of if we can keep some just a bit
of the opposite of the choir stuff on of
hearing birdsong and of and the air is
so clean now
and it really is I'm in London as a
different place I hate I hate what it's
done I miss everything I miss the pubs I
miss people I miss meeting my friends
and my loved ones and my family about
blah but I do feel a lot lot greener
anyway you know I had to you know I
totally agree
even for me it's just it gives you a
chance just to get back to nature
doesn't it everything's a still just
that much greener yeah there was a black
bird in a tree back and I live
overlooking a council estate and
suddenly I'm I'm turning into David
Attenborough there's a small black bird
but it's treating most beautifully and I
just thought well hey this is I would
never have you know give it a second
thought and the time before and that
call you know if a Robin was to appear
here by my window I have an orgasm it's
good always looking for a silver lining
and then everything and but I want to
focus on your work at the BBC because I
think your work as a journalist which
I'd let's go get to that yes yeah but
your work that's me ask me at the end
yeah all right I'm gonna ask you
everything then so your work and will
you are well known for your work as an
investor Jennifer before at BBC Panorama
and as investigative undercover work
goes it can be quite dangerous and it
can get quite messy and we've seen a lot
of that and I want to look at your and
2018 piece taking on Putin because you
did put yourself a quite a vulnerable
position there at times you've been
followed but for us the viewer it is
just TV so I want to know have you ever
actually feared for your safety
yes
what you yes but it's when I was a war
reporter and for the observer from about
1988 to about 2000 that I used to take
it felt like the risks were far greater
certainly when I was a freelance back in
88 I'm just I'm fiddling with running my
memoirs and it feels like running your
own obituary so I keep on not finishing
I'm trying to run a pitch and I keep I'm
not finishing the pitch but I can
remember when surrender and Burundi in
88 was a freelance on my own and I took
terrible risks then and it was grim and
you see awful things
walk through the door I saw report man
would be machetes in the back of the
head that sort of kid was a tiny toddler
with his arm had been amputated and I
took a photograph of her and she cried
and I saw the so flashbacks backs up so
this is physical risk that you take
Sarajevo those places towards the end of
my kind of big-time career I was doing
stuff who knows it may not be over but
certainly the the Putin film that you
know I've got a producer I've got a
cameraman Seamus McCracken I've got a
fixer it's where we're a great gang
we're great
we have great comment I'm gonna say
comradeship I can't pronounce could
camera memory yes I can and he and we
and we knew what we're doing we're very
very disciplined and I use and we were
followed all the time and we just filmed
them following them them following us
them spying on us in various places
either in the habit the creepy Russian
secrets tasty steak people from the FSB
the secret police the new name for the
KGB who was spying on in restaurants and
I used to go up and film them all the
time and so my boss said stop it stop it
stop it you know I said well you know
but I it was it was great fun I look
back to that film with making that film
with great affection and a funny way so
as a as a it's felt it was the best bit
of working for the BBC were in a tough
place we're in the frontline but boy
when we were working together as a team
yes we were it's good and you mentioned
your work The Observer where you saw
some incredibly gruesome things so how
then do you weigh up the pursuit of the
truth you know compared to your safety
how do you sort of say yes this is worth
it because particularly in Russia
it just is that scary and even your work
you know in North Korea which we'll get
to how do you weigh up that it's just
it's a strange
it's Australia sitting in that you're
aware of the risk and you look at it and
you have to fill in forms risk
assessment forms bla bla bla bla bla but
there's a certain point and this has
always been a thing for me I I love
stories I love storytelling and the best
stories the stories powerful people
don't want told so I first my first
really risky story I did in Russia was a
film when I was at the observer and to
the film with channel 4 dispatches about
the war in Chechnya and we went on the
car war in Chechnya and that was super
scary really frightening but I felt so
angry that Vladimir Putin and the entire
Russian military machine and his secret
state were bent on stopping us from
getting there so we all felt can I swear
by the way on this [ __ ] you goddammit
Putin you are not going to [ __ ] stop
me and so what happens is you get this
kind of crazy override it's not crazy it
feels like we're going to do this and
you go for it and then later there a
moment so I did a second thing in
injection or about Chechnya I went there
I went in I got a series of radio
interviews with Chechens who've been
tortured they'll remember them it's a
it's a Muslim country that once
independence Russia would give it as a
tremendous fault line there and some
other people were Islamists who will
have ended up supporting things like
9/11 and the Islamic state but this is
to thousands and the Russian state what
relevant Britain was doing was
unbelievably cruel in terms of torture
and I got the story now listen all these
accounts and then you start I can't
sleep at night and so worse than the
physical fear is the psychological
effects of this stuff on you and I used
to get to sleep bye em bye
I had a copy of PG Woodhouse's code of
the Wooster z-- and and I read vast and
I drink maybe a half maybe three
quarters of a bottle of vodka to get to
sleep and then you wake up in the middle
of the night and go back to Japan I
reread the code of the woods and then
hit some more and and it's just this is
the hardest thing I think then than the
physical fear which generally been it
hasn't bothered me too much because I'm
I'm a bit of a [ __ ] French essentially
you need thick skin but you know I think
it's really interesting to hear that
it's it's not so much just your physical
safety there's also that mental sanity
you know hearing you have to read to get
to sleep or that you have to drink vodka
to sort of make it through the next day
is in a lot you know and I think it's it
it must is very commendable really that
you put the pursuit of the truth and
before your own sanity there but growing
up did you always say yes that's what I
want to do I want to be on the front
line you know I want to be putting my
life at risk
and did you have any self-doubt along
that way when you finally decided yes I
want to be a panorama report or whatever
it whatever it is
did you how much self-doubt was there
getting to that point oh I've always I'm
you would never know but I am my own
biggest critic there's a lot to
criticize I I've got a I've got a fair
measure of self-doubt particularly after
you know I do something and then it's
after what you think what are you doing
what are you doing y'all for when I was
a kid I wanted to be a lawyer and I went
along to a we brought up in Manchester
and then we moved down to Hampshire at
the age of 10 and 15 I went to
Winchester Crown Court got into the back
of a court and it was a raid case and
the defense law I wanted to be defense
floor and ripped the the victim to
shreds and I thought I don't want to do
that that's
morally obnoxious I don't want to be put
in the place where I'm doing something
which just feels completely wrong and I
think as a reporter I have never ever
done something which I I've never done
something against my own will so if
there's a boss who says do that then
there are at times when I will say no
I'm not going to do that and how do you
I mean it feels it's common sense common
humanity also is there another way of
getting to this point without doing that
and it's an argument I mean like you
know some I can remember BBC boss said
that you're impossible to manage the the
deputy editor there was a deputy editor
of The Observer who sent me a snotty a
tourism it was a memo that's before
emails and he wanted me to to do a piece
about the headmaster of the public
school and being caught with a
prostitute and I thought it was a
pathetic story not with the observer
writing about and I refused to do it
and I sent anyway he sent me an angry
murmur back and I sent him a member back
in kind and he sent me a memo back
saying the next time you send them a
memo like that I'm gonna break your
[ __ ] neck
I read they put more pressure on me to
write the piece and I wrote it in verse
in rhyming couplets which was unpretty
only so I wrote the piece but it was a
ton principle it was unprincipled
because clearly it's a as a poem it was
absurd but so I so I I used to do those
kind of game be a point in your career
to be able to do that though a certain
point yes so good eh now what's annoying
now is that the BBC and I'm now having
plates make some ladder
I'm back here I fallen down a snake
Tommy Robert said and now I'm back at
the bottom of the ladder and I'm going
to crawl up again and I've got to be
nice to bosses and it's really it's
really killing me it's difficult to I
mean it's alright because I can my books
and what I can do I hopefully I get what
everything's in trouble because of the
because of the virus but I'm sure
hopefully I'll get through it
hopefully we'll all get through but yes
being a freelance is different it's a
thing as an investigative journalist is
if you're on salary then you have a
strong anchor with which you can you can
write their time the right tides which
running against you the problem is the
moment you're freelance it becomes much
more difficult to say no we're not doing
that because it's not right yeah and as
a Janice myself I can totally relate to
that sometimes you can't always you know
do things the way you want to do them
but just sticking with this topic and
also just looking back because when
you're when you're they're out in the
field things don't obviously always go
to plan and we've seen that with a lot
of news backlash that you've had off the
back of all these different
documentaries so the Scientology one for
example and there was a bit of a riff
something happened
so things don't always go to plan so
when you're there on this scene how do
you make a cool how do you say what I
have to do this I'm gonna do that
because the the documentary could you
get can sort of get shut down I can go
to a whole different direction and then
on top of that you then have to UM you
know explains your colleagues back home
why you made that cool so how do you
deal with that it's kind of remember you
know I'm just the pretty face so I'm the
the gob on a stick and with Scientology
I had a brewery producer Sarah mole and
a brilliant cameraman Bill Brown and the
provost were a fantastic funny team and
they used to take the piss out of me all
the time and I can remember the day the
morning I lost my right back with Tommy
Davis and what you I doubt that I do
another after that beginning of the
interview order but
the I said to Sara listen I don't do
this anymore
because they were so annoying and she's
just said she's real message she said
Chuck get on with your job and lo and
behold kapow ER I lost it and I bill
said after I lost it we managed to run
away from them and have a thing and he's
built overnight over Irish accent but he
said John I got one thing to tell ya I'm
leaving the BBC to join the Church of
Scientology and I was so broken at this
point I thought thought Billy you're
really leaving
I said no [ __ ] off John anyway it's a
are you but I I just at that moment I
just had too much and I couldn't contain
my anger and then then in the middle of
being angry I remembered where we were
and then I said now will you listen to
me and then I went anger again and it's
kind of it's completely weird but it's a
little index of the stress and both bill
and Sarah big soft journalists and me I
suppose doing Scientology the mental
psychological pressure the games they
play it's one of the things that sticks
and in my mind is right you know
whenever you know you get threatening
letters from Bansi lawyers and then I
just go yeah it doesn't compare with
Scientology what's sweet about it is
people have left the church is on the
church is it special in cult they say it
isn't but I don't I think that's
nonsense but
the ex-members said that one of the
reasons they left we're seeing the
church demonize me with that incident
and saying no this there's something
wrong here about the way the church is
telling the story so I'm I feel really
proud of that little moment embarrassing
as it is as it's it actually tells you
more about them than it does about me
and it makes you
it kind of justifies why you did what
you did it doesn't know it doesn't just
what I did was wrong but it's it's it's
it's if you're in the publication lose
your temper however I was on that I'd
been it was the seventh day and I've
been pretty good up to them and then
they were just one of several Dutch
couldn't bury so you were able to make
peace with what you did then yeah well
it's kind of like the public eye we were
undercover in Egypt a couple years ago
Mila BBC producer the airport's
completely empty because the Terrorism
and we were the tourists don't go over
there anymore because of fear of
terrorist attacks and we're in the MD
Airport and I'm meeting an Egyptian
London those says you're that sounds
ology bloke and Jane was my producer was
about 100 yards or well it's at a James
this guy recognizes me from Scientology
and James from the [ __ ] sake we're
supposed to be undercover yes even that
it's interesting right when you just do
so many different undercover pieces of
work
you no longer are undercover anymore
because people recognize you but not in
North Korea right and that's what I want
to get to now because North Korea's a
really interesting one particularly for
me yeah I'm actually which is why I
reached out to you because it's
something actually that when I was at
University studying journalism it was an
ethical dilemma that our lecturers put
to us and then for those that don't know
there was an issue to do with consent of
the students that came with you so they
gave consent but they weren't able to
give informed consent because some
information was held back so can you
talk us through this hat why did you
make that decision well I've written
I've written a book about it north
career on the cover so it's you can find
that on Amazon um but I would say that
the person who complained about what
happened afterwards was 28 one of the
students and she wasn't honest in that
she knew what we were doing she
recognized me she
was interested in being a journalist and
she took us to the fence she got up at 6
o'clock or 5:30 one morning to take me
and the cameraman to the fence when I go
welcome this is the real North Korea so
so and then her father was a very
wealthy man and what happened at the end
towards the end of the trip is that she
was befriended by the North Korean guide
and she I think was in some way turned
by the North Korean guide her father was
a wealthy man very wealthy man and then
applied and then we started getting
nasty legal letters from this man on
behalf of his 28 year old daughter now
the problem with the BBC is the BBC
didn't want to go there and there was a
second problem in that Tony Hall was the
new director general and he was a
different kind of boss but nothing like
as good as Mark Thompson Mark Thompson
was the boss on the scientology and he
said ah essentially we're going to
broadcast this Tony Hawk broadcasts the
North Korea programme because we've been
bad not to but we were it was we weren't
allowed to defend ourselves
in a way that I wanted to do so and it
was difficult I also feel that the there
are roughly a hundred thousand people
locked up in the North Korean gulag at
the moment and our documentary which was
seen by five million people when it went
out talked to that story and actually I
apologize for losing my temper with the
Church of Scientology I do not apologize
for what we did in North Korea
I think in the rome's it was good
journalism it's difficult always
difficult the easy solution is not to go
and therefore you don't get in so I so
that's what I survey about that okay and
we would have this in mind then
because it seems like everything seems
to be done for the greater good and I
think it seems that you've kind of seen
that along the way so what's your
proudest moment within all of this
so the proudest moment has to be the
stories we ran when I first joined BBC
in 2001 and 2002 2003 of our professor
sir Roy meadows expert evidence in which
he he gave evidence that cold death
mothers including Sally Club famously
SATA Clarke use of this a case that she
had murdered her baby boys and he did so
saying that the odds of this happening
was 73 million to one that's not true if
you have if you have a second contact
the odds of happening a one in sixty so
the jury was told something which was
completely untrue and wrong and she was
convicted for murder
and we set out the case that he was
wrong and it was lonely to begin with
and at the end of it she was freed by
the court of appeal and then I helped
free Angela Channing's and then Donner
Anthony and so one year I helped 2003 I
helped free freed mothers who'd been
wrongly accused of murder and that is
best thing I've done in my entire life
apart from having my kids which is
different yeah I mean I think it's
fantastic I think you know with all the
news that happens off there as a spinoff
from all the different documentaries to
be able to say well no I've done this
this and this and that's why I do it and
that's what you know helps you sleep at
night as opposed to the vodka and the
drink and whatever you know it's good to
hear but in times of regrets then is
there anything which just sticks out to
you and says that I should have done
better well so your viewers on the
listeners the podcast will know that I
may know that I tried to do a
documentary about Tommy Robinson and
basically one of his people um affected
to have been away from him but in fact
was still effectively working for him
and the film would be drinking too much
and being a bit of an idiot I don't
think
he said terrible terrible things I think
they were embarrassing but not shaming
and I think that had Mark Thompson still
being the Director General he would have
given me a kick and said huh but the way
it played out was very difficult for me
because the BBC wouldn't put the film
out and and we made her film Tommy
Brothers but they wouldn't put it out
Wilde Tommy Robinson's trolls attacked
me online and also in person the flesh
because I'm a relatively well known
person and so I was I was verbally
challenged at the funeral of Lara and
the key who was a journalist who I knew
a little bit and she was shot dead in
Derry and here's one of Tommy
Robertson's trolls having a go at me so
I run my tongue over again I would have
done that story very differently and
I've been much more aware so that's
something I regret um that I got wrong I
think tragically it's right to do
stories about people on the far right
because they are dangerous I think to to
ask society on the whole there is
nothing that stands out that makes me
think oh my god that was a terrible
thing to do um that that's that may
sound pompous there's nothing I don't I
don't lose sleep about anything about
something I did and I know what happened
in North Korea
don't lose sleep about it I I don't
really sleep about Scientology I'm proud
of the war reporting done so have I made
mistakes yes obviously I'm a human being
we all make mistakes but it it's I don't
there's nothing I'm ashamed of okay I
don't I would talk to you about anyway
maybe for another time maybe another
once we get to the pub exactly I'm just
whining then for young journalists
people looking to get into get into
journalism and what tips and tricks
would you say is the best thing to do
well there's a number of things first of
all be true to yourself and never
actually do and I think that's that's
wrong that you're gonna lose some stuff
about I'm by the way when I was a cub
reporter just remember I used to have
knock on people's doors when they had a
terrible accidents and stuff and there
was one thing poor guy run over his
child
the toddler this car and it was our job
to go knock on the door and I wish I
hadn't done it and and afterwards I
stopped doing those things I'd pretend
to do them but not do them so not want
don't do anything that you know is
morally wrong number two work your
context whoever they are work stories
talk to people if you've got a good
story
then flog it ten times the room this
magazine to a radio station to a
separate radio station to do a podcast
to two new civil engineer if there's you
know I mean you've got to think
laterally this is really hard newspapers
are a massive problem because the virus
TV is becoming more centralized and more
in-house so it's very very difficult but
nevertheless the job of telling truth to
power that doesn't go away and there are
times when it is the best job on earth
like in 2003 like you said John Sweeney
thank you so much it's been an absolute
pleasure having you with us and thank
you so much bees are open and authentic
and honest with us pleasure so there you
have those incredible stories straight
the horse's mouth from North Korea to
Russia it's hot tips to getting into
journalism if you enjoyed this video and
want to hear more incredible stories
like this then hit the like button hit
subscribe
quiet below and let me know who you want
to hear from next week